[Music]
hello happy Monday I'm gonna turn our
mics up because I can't actually hear us
there you go
welcome to GameSpot live today we're
playing blood-borne and were sponsored
by PlayStation now if you didn't know
PlayStation now lets you stream hundreds
of PlayStation games on the ps4 or PC
plus you can also down on any ps4 game
in the service including blood-borne for
honor and until done directly to your
ps4 now not all games are downloadable
but there are some that you can and then
the rest you can stream so you can learn
more at PlayStation now or PS now calm
and we'll give you more details on that
later but for now John Luke let's head
back into yarn oh boy always a good time
we're starting a new game here who are
you gonna make a funky looking character
or you just kind of kind of like like
randomized I'll hit the random button up
old man chatter what a sketball that old
man chat it's gonna get to the game
alright that's good that's fair gender
why not still probably one of the best
PlayStation exclusive games I feel like
on a personal level yeah probably one my
favorite games of all but still holding
out hope one day for some huts okay
where does that random blood-borne juice
one can only hope but we have SEC euro
in like 11 days charlie we do at least
we have that and I'm looking forward to
that as well so excited for that you
know I don't I'm just gonna get rid of
the game I don't want to miss you want
to see the game yes I want to kill some
you look at my face especially like Dark
Souls with the first thing I do is get
like a helmet on my cool when you get
like the doll's outfit and like some of
that others shenanigans stuff I remember
I made my first character and I forgot
why it was like a different version of
the game or something and my that
character was just butt ugly
and then luckily you know after game to
like level 20 something they're like oh
you're gonna have to start all over I'm
like oh that's fine I hate my character
anyways and I think I chose poorly
please tell me you're not gonna pick
that I became let's think about doing it
just to show you but no you want to stop
if you want to have the struggles you
know I'm gonna go with you'll faithful
the saw blade
alright the saw blade is very good and
could be used the entire game actually I
mean most weapons you could argue yeah I
guess that's true but it's so solid it's
very solid Oh which I which thing did
you pick I picked I the default okay Oh
standard assets here
it's deprecated since I've played where
I as far as like bills go okay like I've
done I guess first raise yharnam in
rocket we're not gonna get far enough
for that matter anyway like it's not
like oh you know I get my blood tinge
skill build for when I get the chikage
like what do you think what do you think
what what do you think you'll get to
what I get to yeah I bet I can do
I think pass gas going probably right
you think you'll get to a blood star VSB
I could I could do it I can I've I know
how to like really quickly run through
yeah they do the drop down yeah the
question is then will I be able to beat
him because I blood start was probably
the one that I struggled with the most
okay iris played the game take the take
challenge I mean the the key to if you
want to BBS be early I mean one is
obviously if is uh there are some I
forget what's called already but the
anti poison helps a lot the anti poison
helps
he is Perry able yeah I parry all day
gube says take the Tate challenge I
challenged him and I showed him on my
own stream that I did I could kill vs be
no problem without leveling and he said
I cheated still somehow you're the
blessed bus huh
pistol life okay so sock cleaver or yeah
I'm about the first to I hate that the
right became I'm sorry I like the thirty
cane right I know but it's it struggles
earlier right like let's be honest it
struggles a law earlier but it can get
better I just I've never been a fan of
be it's definitely the weaker
of the skill weapons like Matt for me
the skill the the high skill weapons are
chikage was my favorite okay
unfortunately get that very late the
dual blades are very good yeah
blades are also pretty good blades of
mercy I think I'm not yes you have to
kill currently Manos we're not we you
can download blood-borne via PS now
which is what we did earlier it's also
being sponsored by PS now but you can
download or stream it that way max is
the best is philanthropy ax is pretty
strong because that one are a heavy
attack where you like when you hit a
smaller target it just slams them into
the ground
and so so good cyborg man that says Jim
Kirk play Kurt blade is wait no I'm not
a crook player camera I'm a lewd wings I
think I'm a Ludwig's boy Kirk I'm not a
ker camera guy that was cool but I can't
use a hammer yeah let me smoke him no
problem I think there were some files
back there if you care tell me I don't
know how much you practice I didn't want
to call the speedrun I just want this I
wanted to call it like a let's see how
far we get in ninety minutes kind of
thing you know I figured you know I
won't speed through it but I'm oh yeah
yeah yeah fight over the weekend I
actually forgot that this weekend wasn't
I was just playing it yes
mass Benelli was like playing a lot of
blood-borne in anticipation for SEC Euro
it's like a posted DMC thing else
there's like some more goodies down here
yep
I feel like alright cuz I don't know how
much gameplay footage you watch because
I've only watched a little bit of SEC
euro as well but the whole like being
able to kind of like you know jump off
trees and stuff was kind of throwing me
off oh these are like watching already
off to a bad start
so I think I think we're in for a little
bit of a learning curve
I wouldn't say like a big learning curve
but I think like you know to really hone
in on that style of gameplay I think
there's gonna be some some nice things
for
the first thing I definitely know it's
weirdly enough because I just know it's
weird things with that is I know so use
the exact same um typeface on the you hi
like yeah that's the same uh same
letters yeah same typeface yeah iron
from I says B's clause yeah B's clause
are a bunch of a load of fun once you
get into old hunters especially when you
can finally turn cyborg man wants you
not just give cleric piece oh oh no I
won't skip cleric beast that's not it's
clear please not too bad if you even if
add the other fun fact is if you could
pick up some Ollie's small tongs
it makes cleric beast pretty easy a
little bit easier too because you can
definitely crit them in the face burn
him up you know he's got all those
feathers saw cleaver for level 4 runs
he's probably not gonna do a level 4 run
but saw cleaver is definitely never done
like level runs a very good handy weapon
never been something I've done this is
I've never really gotten to like there
was a game I would ever do that for like
a speedrun like this one probably be at
the top when we talked about it forever
about having to be right you know the
funny thing was I was gonna I was joking
with Nick Sherman he's a project manager
who helps us kind of like coordinating
streams it's like you know me and John
Luke haven't talked about what Bourne
speedrun for a longest time what if we
did that during the PlayStation now
streaming you say oh that sounds pretty
cool but would would that all
technically be good and all that I was
like yeah and then I was like maybe we
should just because it adds so many
layers but I had a lot of fun doing the
the monster hernán one with Ben that I
was like oh we could totally do this
with blood-borne
you're fighting the spicy boy early huh
I respect that
I gotta practice my time yeah I got a
good back oh right in the stomach all
right
needs one more nice yep
and it gets so much better when you get
the runes later it's like oh it's just
so much more he'll back off the stagger
and the I suppose reviled in here right
or did you get on there it's okay it was
good for the souls yeah we always joke
about that with like extra life might be
a fun thing to do we should do it I
think this year why not speed around
like a little two-hour three-hour thing
see who gets farther kind of thing
that'd be fun
it takes some practice I do it was a New
Game+ run so but I did do it in like 3-4
hours one time
Mike got to the ending nice I did it to
get the final achievement to get the
third ending oh you did every ending but
the final ending just let him kill you
yes oh yeah I think that's the only one
I didn't do too actually and then I was
just like I don't care about platon I
mean which is a weird thing to say
it's really weird thing to say cuz I was
so I don't know I was I was exhausted by
the time I went back and you know
realized oh I gotta get intestines and I
got four of them actually that's the
funny thing is if you guys didn't know
there's actually four sports or there's
like yeah there's four that you can get
it's pretty cool means if you missed one
which is very possible there was other
ways to kind of get that third one and I
had no idea
it's the clinic who's the one you just
get randomly in the
you get one from the chick with the red
heat or the the heels I think if you I
think forget it's like after she gives
birth of something it's like yeah it's
it's the it's the clinic yes it's the
clinic it's the woman can give birth
that's the tough one to get I believe
and then because you have to do some
very specific stuff to get that one yeah
one I think there's one you just find in
the what we called the school right and
then I think you automatically get one
for beating her go the witness that was
always a weird one for me was a Virgo
didn't feel that like difficult
relatives are like the other stuff you
fought like right before that Yeah right
like that was like the weird thing for
like Airmen huh like why why are you she
like sort of the last whatever it's fine
best weapon PvE ludwig's people asking
what's the best weapon I think it's
subjective I mean my favorite is your
chica gay he's really good if you get
that a skill blood-tinged like Bill
going it's really good the blood pinch
weapons are really good something about
lewd wigs always felt like a great
all-rounder because to hand and single
or simple handed both felt really good
now are we talking pre old hunters or
post old hunters cuz they add so much so
many weapons cuz the rakuyo is like
really fun to use yeah yeah yeah the
rakuyo is also it's a very similar vein
of the chikage as well
with rakuyo is also did it bother you
that like you didn't actually get that
from maria like one area where there's
those toes like socks like big Whaley
boys just like flopping around and
you're like man all I want is the rakuyo
just please leave me alone
and it's like this really small like
area to fight and these these big boys
just they can ruin your day oh nice so
the goal here would be at minimum we're
gonna try to kill cleric we're gonna try
to kill Gascoigne hopefully maybe get
our way and kill blood start because you
can kill three I'll be pretty good I
mean the only other boss like that's
near there I guess would be Amelia maybe
or you'd make a run to the witch I guess
oh that one's I'm less familiar with
that area's charnel is eternal eternal
hem with the turnover hit him and I
forget all this why I really should go
back before this game I play like the
beginning a bit and then I'm like I got
my face it felt good I'm good for
another year Oh
sniper coop as soon as I found Ludwig's
that's all I used
yeah Ludwig's is just really good in
general very like I said I had fun with
the moonlight blade to God that battle
that boss that Ludwig's was he he
devastated me he was probably by far the
hardest boss for me in blood-borne I
think art hands down for Bernie actually
he was maybe the second hardest but the
harnesses knee is actually the visitor
Brutus no it's the the watchdog and the
chalice dungeon know if you heard the
child stop yeah I did all of them
they're there
are if you want to get to yarn him the
Sumerian Queen you gotta be as like fire
watchdog okay yeah yeah yeah sucks he I
remember he was pretty bad actually
that's a good she I was the worst lawn
by the way if you want to fight a really
cool boss try to get to that the Marion
Queen I think she's one of the coolest
bosses in the game I don't know and she
just had different move sets that I
didn't really see prior and the whole
like baby crying thing was like creepy
AF it's cool like from the lore
perspective
you also need our beater if you want to
get the so see I'm really close I guess
I should go back and do the easy here
just chop my head off and oh I was
dreaming
yep I've been dreaming this whole time
holding his dream
well they have feet but they don't
really use them are you gonna grab that
armor in the sewer or are you just gonna
kind of rock day one
what's the armor in this whoo yeah it's
um it's not one like old hunter set the
one that like where you drop where the
rats are oh oh yeah yeah maybe it's up
to you to grab the one outside of the
waiting but the old brick boy are
knocking on the door you don't have good
practice for Perry what's up boxing how
you doing hey you the hardest one for me
is warrants ooh Lawrence is a good shot
too all the way back I was pretty tough
Lawrence is tough however I he's the
he's the optional one and the he's a
fire yeah he's we're so unfortunate
little higher level pretty quick he gave
me some problems too just because his
phase one and phase two are pretty neat
pretty rough you the orphan of cause
though mmm that one's tough because he
does not relent yeah he jumps around
he's no he's no joke like you have so
little breathing room with him and it
really sucks as much as our favor cost
sucks for me somehow Ludwig really
ruined probably Ludwig really ruin my
day
what's up PSW I can't I can't say the
whole party name sorry
come here boy ah these are the fun
things that you can do bring the dog
gate or I like to bring the wolves to a
narrow passage a narrow door and I
cheese them through the door oh yeah
yeah the Wolves up there yes Oh Dom b67
favorite boss considering all aspects
question mark says mer goes wet-nurse
boss design setting soundtrack come on I
do really like the soundtrack and I
think it's a cool looking boss for sure
there's like two like sides it has I
just thought I wish you was harder I
don't I I it's not really what I was
like why I don't know yeah I don't know
if it was just all the other stuff we
had to deal with before that that made
her seem not as hard but when I got to
her just didn't seem as impactful I
don't know why I mean my favorites Marie
yeah I got super lucky with her I don't
know how I ended up beating her and the
time that I did but she's a fun boss by
I tend to be able to deal with the human
bosses a little bit easily
okay good trait possibly if he's dead
we're good yeah okay there's a good
trade those are the best kind of trades
is like even though you get hit you get
the stagger and then you just get that
sweet life back oh yes Cecil Colonel
it's um it's a hard game when you but
once you start getting used to it like
it works out also blood-borne in general
is just favors a little bit more of an
aggressive style so you know in regards
to this - Dark Souls like it's a little
bit friendlier in that you get life back
on hit and things like that but it's
still a hard game some people will say
not that hard some people saying hard
but fun
I think it depends on your experience
the DLC definitely ramps up as des
ninjas success Realty is DLC specific
isn't ridiculously hard yeah in
comparison yes this is true and which I
liked actually it is weird that the one
day hello Wow like yeah that's true
actually yeah like if you could like oh
you wanna beat Vic Amelia and then go to
this other area yeah and you're like no
I don't actually I really don't want to
lose this thing taking me somewhere
somebody said Amidala as one of the
harder bosses that one could be tough
and that one can be tough for sure
I think her plan is to prepare for
sector up kind of but mainly because I
wanna play it we have a PlayStation now
sponsorship and this is the one game I
was like we have to have this one if
they're gonna they gotta give me this
one please
oh well we won't get far enough to get
the pizza cutter or the whirligig sob
but that is a fun weapon really exhaust
cool yeah that's a fun that's a fun
weapon I never really got good at the
the wheel though that thing is supposed
to do deeps the what's-his-name's is
that one priests the one that really
just goes to town on what's her name in
cainhurst oh man you come back like
everything's just dead nice to look area
sir know that right the guy you it's
them is it a martyr I'll find out and it
is the ligarius wheel
who I'm sure I'll find out in a second
I did not Oh Alfred its Alfred Alfred
that's there he is
yes but man does he go to town yeah
someone's asking about it's double my
cry five worth buy absolutely it is it's
great game we give it a 9 out - whoo
that's yeah yeah I needed a hopping to
that I was watching the tweet you sent
out about the like all the combo vids
cause also they're so good it makes me
want to get better at the game but also
I'll never be that good but I mean you
can see it like it's one of those
fighting game things right if you want
to learn it you can see what people are
doing is trying to mimic because will
they specifically show they're good the
controller yeah they're press but you
watching you're also like but you watch
this one spinning move and you're like
oh it's probably just like you hold it
down and you're like no no he's like
tapping it precision every time and
you're like oh that's way harder than it
looks we will not skip the cleric beasts
we said we'll go kill that yeah that
that big boy so we're gonna go do that
second iron from Isis gehrman was a best
boss fight for them he's like pretty
good too I like that one of his scythe
that's not really on New Game+ weapon
alright thank you guys all for tuning in
if you guys didn't know where you were
playing blood-borne ah yeah we are
playing blood-borne sponsored by
PlayStation now you can learn more about
PlayStation now at PS now calm this game
in particular you can download there are
many other games that you can download
as well others that you just have to
stream good trade it'll work out maybe
not work out it's okay you got most of
your life back see that that's part of
the regain system that I was talking
about that you know helps kind of ease
players in because you know get that
light back it's almost like having
lively you get some insight look at that
I volunteer yeah I'll get the one
insight from him showing up
that's awesome God for proud of you
proud that you beat this game in three
days with no help oh [ __ ] I think I did
it
because I'm I'm live streaming this
entire game
nothing like staying in the pocket right
this is one of those bosses about today
in my position right now
good well so I forget the stagger is
definitely like what his face and then
like is it the weak arm that does like
smaller arms yes it's a smaller arm
right yeah like that yeah John we could
still work
right in them
yeah well angry yeah that camera yeah
that is the one thing that happened then
especially with Lisa
[Music]
it's like very good epic all I gotta say
is screw Lawrence yeah Lawrence is a
pain in the butt
there's a lot there's a couple I like
that everyone has like that boss that
like they just hate yeah mine is jiggly
okay good let's get some space all right
you started the first part of the fight
great he's he's had a bounce-back round
two we're gonna head in around three
here are you a fan of the charge attacks
I never really did a good I know I never
use him the first time but I kind of
like started to figure them out when I
learned that you can use them to stun
them I got you something I want to live
I never really like got a hang of it
yeah just I didn't bother with it much
in there
I also yeah I also don't do a good job
of doing the combos into like the weapon
switches because I know a lot of people
do that especially with the saw blade
for like Lance DPS or whatever whoo got
lucky there I was gonna say yeah yeah I
know I'm not good hello that's all right
only halfway
molotovs dude yeah he only has one
anyways I think he all know I lied he
has not gotten on oh yes yeah Mali's are
a hard counter you can get 50 him
another basic at the time just feels
definitely staggered all right though
right through the Wicked's I've had that
for that yeah how you like that you like
fired thanks for the tip - here that's
right when I play the weekend I was
fully you just wanted to swag on it you
know you just want to show that the
audience your saw blade gameplay
spanking them but a bad bad Clarisse
whoa
anyway geez it's gone berserk blue
darkness our old gave me a tough time
but I've seen someone just obliterate
him cuz like yeah people just know what
they got to do to like stagger them yeah
yeah and it makes them like a joke
because he doesn't have like half the
electric attacks that he has and it
becomes like a trivial fight almost
which it's good happen which you could
argue happens with a couple of these
bosses actually if you really know the
rhythm and say mmm
got him yes one try cool yes okay one
boss down no deaths so far keep going
looking good now on to father Gascoigne
you'll play a speed run without co-op I
mean one day we'll do a speed run like
in in her in office speedrun we'll see
who who does better in like akima I
think an extra life would be a fun one
to do that for Kobe these guys at the
Bell
I hate put dirt bees para
yeah he's a he's a side one too right if
I don't if I recall correctly is you
could totally skip him I mean all he has
is a shortcut a shortcut to an area that
you've already been so he's yeah they're
just for them for the challenge of it
Kirk hammer have enough yet though you'd
really go Kirk hand right here I don't
know Chuck at the hunter garb we get a
free one though well I guess in the sake
of time I guess you should just do what
you can did you did you eat all your
dues and stuff I haven't actually
yeah daughter of Cosmos was pretty tough
cuz she had that one move the laser
tracking Lube or like you just add the
dodge the whole time it's like man come
on give me a break and then some of our
moves are like [ __ ] cuz you couldn't
like with the camera you couldn't tell
if she was gonna do one or not and like
some of those were like almost instant
kills once again that was one where I
found it like at the end of the game oh
because you're way over leveled for it
[Music]
and I felt bad I was like I was supposed
to have been here earlier I stopped
playing on the sync wars but this makes
me want to play again you should totally
do it money you got it you got to do it
because it's actually like the the DLC
is actually really good like I like that
it was like one big deal see instead of
two small ones you know cuz they made it
like one big one was it like some small
ones and then they decided to make it
one big one and it was really good
except there's like one kind of like the
stupid but there's like one stupid boss
out of like a plant or something right
what are they called
basically it's like a multi version of
the mushroom guy that's in that you
fight before yeah but that was such a
duck like I was like really like you
have so many cool bosses and this is the
one throwaway woman like right after
that get Maria right Maria exactly
philanthropy is here he he lurks
he definitely lurks oh that was pretty
dirty but nice reactions there I get
this guy too
so satisfying that that made my second
run all the more fun is when you really
start to master the stagger master the
timing cuz I'm not gonna lie I was
pretty chicken [ __ ] the first time I
played through where I didn't really
have a handle on staggering and so I
didn't do it as much but the second
playthrough was all about staggering for
me alright opening up some hot shortcuts
I don't fight those guys again
yeah are you just gonna make a run for
that elevator shortcut or we go oh yeah
what's your plan here I do it just level
up a little bit okay go some dogs that
are in cages put them this guy trying
barb in that push her off the ledge or
something I've never really tried to do
it but I've watched people who are like
oh yeah it really depends if you want
the blades I guess but your bill is your
building for going that way because
otherwise they get the blades it takes a
really long time to get them and then
you have to do in my opinion one of the
hardest non boss yes I agree that guy is
a pain in the ass that guy is in the
church guy that basically Eileen loses
sue right okay his name but he's who's
insane I remember the first time I
thought I was like yes he's almost dead
and then he drinks the vial and I'm like
oh you son-of us because he's got the
boat in there or what what's that one um
alright um that lets you do that kind of
like the -
yeah it's really good man got it go to
get the hunters armor yeah he could go
get that too which is something I asked
about earlier but remember that is it's
uh back near the top of the wolves where
the sewers are into the series yeah it's
not this way yeah cuz you're able to
drop down from the top you drop down
into the pit where those like half-body
guys are crawling around oh oh no I'm
about to come across them I know yeah
but you can't get up there unless you do
it from the top
so Oh Oh from the bridge I wanna pass
the bridge yeah yeah like it was near
the area you were just now were the two
wolves you killed were yeah it's
basically a little bit farther I know
what you're talking about
yeah and they drop down cuz those those
like half werewolves II dudes with
Spears and stuff it's up to you if you
think you need the armor if you think
you're good then don't worry okay I like
it
confident man did you even end up buying
that armor just now no okay yeah how
John how been that was exactly how he
wrote it cool good love your work they
say thank you old hunter bone yes thank
you Ray as a senpai that's what it is
gosh so many things remember
[Music]
Oh Wesley ek says get the right rifle
spear upgraded a few times hold r2 and
boy you got yourself a Stu going I know
that feeling you watch out for the
sniper okay yep is this me it's a bread
hole short stream record killer for the
plates yeah but how long would we spend
trying to kill her is the real question
yeah she ain't no joke man Ilene ain't
no joke if you didn't yes I rely ibly
knew how to like quickly kill her I
would do it but I don't so I don't think
it's worth taking the risk what build
are you going for I think he's probably
just gone like whatever the best
all-rounded build for just getting us
through as many bosses as poss exactly
just some strength and yeah the old day
one like you know your first run-through
of the game where you're going like
stamina endurance and like whatever
weapon you know you're ending up using
wayde's of my favorite weapons as
Pantera that's the other cool thing
about blood words just how like so many
different weapons like people like so
many different weapons and I prefer the
way blood-borne doesn't over Dark Souls
where it's you have like X amount yeah
you have like a ton of different types
of weapons and there are more minor
changes where this is like there's you
know only a certain number of weapons
definitely prefer that system yeah you
can argue in a way like they're two
weapons in one sort of right depending
on which order you have go kill cast can
come out oh we on it
oh yeah we're making our way you've got
to get that shortcut though to make
things all I did a bit speed here are
you gonna get the music I've never
actually used the music box I don't know
if I still have the clip but a long time
ago when I was fighting Gascoigne when
he was in beast warm I glitched him out
and then I thought like I was screwed
and then like a couple minutes later he
just disappeared and said you know slain
I was like all right got gas more he's
stuck in a tree and he he decided to tap
out but I really enjoy staggering gas
cooling he's pretty easy to - what's up
Jonathan Mule better late than never
though for sure thanks for coming
yeah crime can't wait for sectio is this
using feeis now currently we downloaded
it via PS now but I have personally
played it via the streaming service and
it was fine but granted we have pretty
good internet in the office so hard for
me to compare that but that's personal
experience by the way I don't think so
that could turn it on it can help a
little bit nailed it this is one of
those games that I desperately wanted
them to do yeah sure or something not
even remaster or something like a
PlayStation Pro support just let me play
this let me pick the option to have an
improved framerate have this game run
and there are at least a solid 30 yeah
there are some there are definitely some
moments for sure then it gets a little
like that's the uh-oh you could kind of
go get the armor now in a way music-box
need that army okay that fine line is
really sad
basically the only way for that little
girl to not die is to just never talk to
her
it's really depressing so Anthony stoked
for Secura I think a lot of people in
the office are stoked really looking
forward to it I'm kind of curious how
[Music]
how that stealth type stuffs gonna play
out also interesting like how much you
can talk about this thing so okay so
technically above there like the it's in
there oh okay yeah yeah yeah and it's
literally where that guy is on that
corner I know but I mean here's so far
along now that and like you said you
don't really think you need it so I
wouldn't worry too much about it hello
well you can you can you can download
this one okay bear but it's currently
downloaded for us it's about 27 gigs I
think it's only the original bloodborne
though doesn't have old hunters yeah I
think it does because it said um I got
the old hunter badge well we'll find out
no no cuz I got the old hunter badge
which played blood-borne welcome Sakura
and I might have been a patch maybe I
don't know
crying says you can play without stealth
yeah but the stealth kills are make it
way like easier to like kill something
though we're secure oh I mean I kind of
want to play it stealth fully just
because that's how the game is and
that's sort of a new experience yeah how
do you think that games kind of mimics
woo who knows I mean they've always been
something like in everything there's
none in blood-borne but but I was so
paranoid after dark souls that I I still
hit every single chest but isn't there
sort of the easy way to tell it based on
how the change that the direction the
changing the duration the change but
because of a blood-borne they were
different looking chest and I just
wasn't sure I was like at some point
it's gonna happen they're gonna throw in
one at the very end so every chest I did
that to those so paranoid
John Hills house sauce beer up by the by
the crowd yeah
no yeah I don't like stab that pig I
think it's I think it's just a worse
version of the isn't there something in
there to forget what's in there there's
something actually these is the bloody
messenger if you do the crest line for
the girl okay
alright getting the shortcut
curve or lesson just stick your looks
sick AF yeah looking forward to it I
mean the gameplay definitely got me
excited sure run back in I don't know
it's your call
totes your call going on it's really
quick um goob I think even though you
can insta-kill from above they're
usually like enemies and packs kind of
so even if you kill one you're gonna end
up fighting another one from what I've
seen so far but it's only seeing a very
small slice of it is this the new DLC no
this is not hunter this is just
blood-borne from the beginning we've
killed the cleric beast or John Luke's
killed the cleric beast or on our way to
Gascoigne thank you guys all for tuning
in if you guys didn't know we're playing
blood-borne via PS nel PlayStation now
you can find out more at PS now comm
split born stream is sponsored by
PlayStation now so thanks for tuning in
that's a cold cold blood dude I like
never use those the first time I played
about remembering that although in like
Dark Souls it was a tough decision
though because in some cases when you
beat bosses is like do I want their
weapon or do I want a lot of souls yeah
I wouldn't always took the weapon I
would really look up what the weapon was
it was something I care about but yeah
you're right father gas can yeah the gas
kid I think we do have the music box
though so we're doing a music box I can
use it I'll be a little fun it doesn't
help that much to be honest I think it's
just kind of cool that it works like
that's a fun little like story thing
yeah gotta wear ask me why I'm wearing a
cap inside am I trying to be cool no but
if I took it off I'd have Bed Head
and so you know I think instead of
having better yeah keeps my hair down
it's it makes it so I don't have to gel
my hair for the day anytime you see me
wear like a beanie it's like a lazy day
right
my hair like such a mess and I'm like
yeah where'd it be neat today it's a
beanie day but also I mean like in
timing for Sachi row it actually makes
sense to kind of just like revisit
blood-borne experience and enjoy some
from games before you know the release I
mean I had fun with dark souls 3 be
honest I really liked it was like a good
kind of like hybrid II you know what
blood-borne is my personal favorite but
I Lois people can agree with that pretty
divisive like I remember there being I
remember I thought it was like the best
thing ever but then I remember getting
really mad I like a couple outlets or
whatever they're like yes it's okay but
I just think one or Dark Souls better
and I was like you're wrong wrong it's
so good
well maybe is the purists and then I and
then I came here and I found out
everyone here like blood where am I good
I'm among my people who's my folks
yeah like yes yeah and like am I guess
this was the one that got me into it and
I'm happy to have played this one this
one was probably a good one to sit like
a good vehicle to kind of get into it oh
yeah think like getting into like dark
souls 2 off the bat would have been
tough well yeah I heard most people this
game for to you the way a lot of people
hate to I don't think it's a bad game
like if people are like it's trash I'm
like no it's not bad but it's marginally
the one that's on the bottom right of
the tears it's hard to pinpoint but
there's something about the way that
game moves that I don't like something
about like the movement and the
animation speed is different in a way
that I I really don't like it in that
super nitpicky but it's just like well
that's also the one he didn't really
like Miyazaki didn't really work on it
right like you just like kind of like
this
helping oh wow I think that's also a
game that's that does watch out it's
coming yeah getting too hard just for
the sake of being hard I suppose they
all avoided it
it's very rare yeah you're not wanted
yeah
I think most of these games are like
challenging but fair and I think darts
let's do actually does go into like just
kind of [ __ ] sometimes they're like
hey how about you fight four of these
guys who can all kill you in one hit
that game loves to do like multi boss
fights like a lot and you're like dude
like slow down Jesus PS we 60 says best
waifu doll or sure I made it I don't
know I made him black from souls there
you go the same voice adoption same
voices the I think it's the is it it's
either the same voice is the doll the
same voice is the shrine maiden in three
I forget which one nice day bear doll
for eighty Sevilla was my first didn't
realize what I was getting myself in
that is a long game it was good news
long and it's very tough I like how it
has some of those shared things but it
does its own thing to like with the
skills for weapons and things like that
it does enough that it I think it really
stands out on its own yeah and the era
that it was in which helped as well sure
well that got secular though yeah true
although it's a crow seems like it's
going enough for its own thing as well
that all these games can stand on their
own
now let's go
there
[Music]
aha
Neil combat stances are an amazing
mechanic yeah I never really did enough
in between but yeah you definitely could
combo and stuff off of it dude if you
guys ever played neo when it first came
out of like a Lafleur baby no god that
game was brutal
that game was tall like holy smokes like
he would get to shot it was insane
and then by the time it came out I was
like wow this is so much easier
okay go go I did him in one shot
over the weekend let's see if I can do
it alright was that with music box it
wasn't the music box okay just want to
give everyone what really got me is that
I got the Perry's down I find that like
in second form the fighting at the top
is easier for me she never fight I've
never done that I don't know why it was
always easier for me up top and I think
I glitched him by like going to like the
roof of where that gem is and dropping
down and so no oh where do you go like I
don't know where he is I hear his ass
but you go get rekt now we'll see I will
say it father gascoigne is what made me
want to use the via axe because man he
made that [ __ ] look
what's wrong all right you know music
not to your ears I've actually never
seen the fight this way
this is kind of cool it's also
interesting that you don't actually oh
you do have to play okay you play it too
then okay already what OH does the music
box we can do that sooner I think so
okay cuz like you plea this is like a
50%
dottie silly that is the one thing I
don't think Slughorn handles well when
they get these aerial text the camera
gets real I turned him down all day you
know angry
[Applause]
hello there we're blowing out our
speakers holy crap
that was the audio it was a gamble there
and yo I messed up the intensity with
the sling all right bang all right
bummer sorry you got the short cut I do
it'll be pretty quick yeah that's what I
was saying I've never seen him phase
three that fast ever if you use the box
too much it forces it early okay that
makes sense because man does he go ham
when he's in monster mode does rip -
that's rip 1 rip 1 death number one you
know such a yeah you don't count the
first death ok yeah no you don't count
such F press f to pay respects what up
you're right this time got a war but you
won't be right this time no I I have
confidence we've evolved we we know what
his weaknesses are we're good
besides in order to get to BSB we got
40-ish minutes so jeez man I feel like
you can get there yeah yeah yeah that or
you can fight Amelia you will fight her
instead because she's real close to the
next checkpoint I feel like you're meant
to fight do you think you're meant to
fight BSB before Amelia I think so okay
cuz I feel like she's harder than he is
but I guess if you have a fire paper
she's not as bad okay I got two out of
the four not bad make sure I'm topped
off you decided in his eyes
Miyazaki son would have been like
smiling and delight at that death
probably like yes mm-hmm or death
some people want you to skip the enemies
good but this is warmup you know this is
warm-up before getting the Gascoigne you
know getting reestablishing the
confidence just these guys
Pantera volume says I've always thought
that shotgun was harder than the pistols
of time pairs is that just me I think
it's just depending on what you're used
to it might be I'm just for me I'm used
to the for me personally I'm used to the
pistol yeah it's really just whatever
one of these whoa he comes in spicy
he's gone yeah he's got the blunderbuss
to write actually useful so he gets a
spread on his pistol and that's some BS
oh that live is so sick
hey buddy he doesn't know slow he's
father gascoigne are you stunning with
this music
I love it I love you how you just talks
do you wanted just bite it talk about
sitting just like I'd be afraid of this
man alright this is true phase 2 where
he yeah switch weapon oh my lord what a
timely sidestep okay there always a baby
here
young man's death roll of the old double
chug
Wow not a place okay reset the fight
get the Wolverine combo berserker
barrage
which in this hard it's okay you're
still alive
they stock
okay I think he's still alive we do not
all have it yeah that was bad rip - Oh
like garbage this is where I think the
pistol is killing so you know why
because I feel like the blunderbuss
takes a little bit more of a like a wind
it does but you get more spread yeah I
know throw a pebble fresh it's true
great tip right there great tip F we're
good we're good
third time's a charm I'm uh slightly
related I guess but I found out over the
weekend you can kill somebody with
Bangalore's gas canister yeah it doesn't
like ten damage III threw a smoke and I
happen to hit someone who was down and
it just killed them nice
I've had that killed me before and I was
like oh sick I love stuff like that
there's a good time in a DMC five where
Dante throws a rose in reference to DMC
for and it does a little bit of damage
nice so it's like Dudley's Rosie play a
little bit you could you kidnap thinking
ultra four you could a combo off of it
you could do your ultra off of it
Johnny Cage has the one we throws two
classes now and eleven
I'm getting excited for that game
alright the Morelos
the beta is actually this or that the
stress test or whatever is that this
week at this week really teen on the dog
too many things happening ooh
that might be good for you guys actually
that would be good for us it is the 15
minute
that's Friday oh well perfect then
that's great third time's a charm
haha not in blood-borne it is here on
gamespot live a whole tactical roll out
there how well would a hunter do in
dorsals i think a hunter would fare very
well I think so alright I'm feeling good
oh we're out the gate huh yeah pretty
standard box going
max I'm interested in David on but I
need to see more you're curious Adam
Oscar and some more data kind of like a
impressions of what they saw so far it's
all gays watch it's not song as well as
the YouTube YouTube got thoughts I can't
spot but right now we are playing
blood-borne and fighting the father
gascoigne sponsored by first of all
thank you guys for tuning in you want to
know more about PlayStation now about a
PS not off on staggered ok phase 2
playing that music
alright thanks 3
nice I'm talking about get staggered Bob
goes in to do it
Oh
Thanks
okay he let you have that one nice I
like that you took it safe you didn't
even do the hop board oh he barely does
actually delay
whoo
good waiting there nice is this it yes
there's several times a time alright
stop bad as I had predicted or injustice
everyone has different bosses that they
can claim that they're good at and bad
against and that's just how it goes
that's kind of the beauty of bullhorn I
feel like definitely in Dark Souls same
thing yeah I got a war there will be no
rip joke's on you Mina plays says hello
I was watching your uncharted history of
and then I saw that it said live and I
loved commenting in a large house by the
way can I get a shout out there's your
shout out and thanks for watching the
history of Uncharted that's awesome I
have a ton of those - mom there's a new
one history of DMC don't cry there you
gather grants guys problem with blood
warns that 20 pots feels like way too
many yeah I don't think the game was I
mean it's to help bring more people in
right what just having 20 pots and be
having it being you know farmable and
stuff like that oh yeah I mean I'm I
still prefer the Dark Soul system not
because I think it's too many but
because it avoids the also has more
tension I guess it avoids the grinding
that you eventually have to do like you
get really stuck at a boss yeah
I just got real quick oh so I can tell
them to get all the people here and
that's where you get a lot of that
optional content that's I'd like
completely missed that the first night
it's really easy to miss all that stuff
yeah okay what are we feeling we're
getting have you done a history of souls
born yet no but we'll see
and the more insight you get the more
these guys become these guys call these
guys the Jabbawockeez sure
I think that uh I don't want to be SB
you have 30 minutes I feel like you
could do it 30 minutes
PSB maybe you want to go old hunters I
can't do that sir
top hat good for those really big boys
that uh and we look fancy no fancy AF I
love the coat I don't like the top hat
but I don't think oh yeah are we doing a
web star I think so if you can get there
why not all right let's try to do it
I believe 30 minutes everyone start as
always my give Eric the gamepad real
easy loss how dare you throw me in there
as I'm not warmed up anymore and without
my pistol my trusty handy pistol I like
a private violin I mean we'll see I mean
I'm willing to give it one go later I'll
go and cold I don't know if it'll be
good you know if he kills him in one
shot than whatever what PSP the blood
start piece it's just the acronym that
the community has given him the
Backstreet Boy
we've been all that skin just walking
around guys my best beats playing I
don't even know if it was on point
it's play some smiling sounds and you're
good yeah the old blood start I know how
you play you can do it thanks for the
confidence I guess I would start stairs
to stagger bedside though oh yeah that
is my 100% tactic it's just annoying
because of the poison especially if you
don't have the antidote
holy smokes he just starts like spamming
with just poison and you're like oh well
my life is melting that's great it's not
even about having the vials to the heal
it's about how much can you get rid of
the poison and like if you fail a couple
times on you and that means you're
farming again to try to buy antidotes
and stuff like that and it gets super
annoying cuz it's like knowing how many
you have right now it's probably like
very for you if any at that or gonna
talk to offer for that paper yeah I'll
talk to him yeah get some fire paper
sick and prescient and oh right I can't
do the shriek though he did transformers
weapon multiple times actually if you
watch the so chilled every time he
finished his combo he swapped to the
secondary and I think for what I've seen
most people use a kind of this form when
so life I don't like using no huge big
blood war feel short you guys the whole
definitely not at all there's so much
side content yeah like well almost half
the game is optional and if you do
everything I mean I get in for smokes
cainhurst area really cool cool boss
Amidala it kind of a pain in the ass is
own actually because of the frenzy [ __ ]
yeah it is a game you can do quickly if
you just if you skip it if you skip all
the optional stuff it is kind of short
but even then I wouldn't say it's like
sure
and even there's alien territory if you
want to go do some of that yeah yeah
like The Nightmare Realm is optional
this area's outdoors this area yeah -
you don't need to do the blood starve
beast at all
Pemex Charlene's optional upper cathedra
Ward's optional
we definitely haven't used its second
form too much but even for me I don't
know I used I I definitely used first
form way more than I did the extended
form I don't know just me yeah that's
just kind of roll oh yes here you go
there's something in here - I forgot
what it is but hey I'm writing your
eyeball down the neck actually the
jugular go to sleep so I'm going to make
the decision to not deal with the turret
guy yeah you're just gonna run by it
right
yeah because yes he's a pimp it's a pain
in the butt to fight the only way to
really kill him early is if you get him
to roll off yep we did it last night cuz
like I've tried to fight him legit and
he's just too hard he's doing he's just
got too much life even when you stagger
him you're like oh that did like no
damage yeah it's better just to run past
him I think your characters female right
yep I think you know yeah the DLC you
can take hours the DLCs pretty long too
if you do like everything as well and if
you get stuck on bosses like I did cuz
whoo boy yeah yeah that Aries um that
Gale sees no joke like the fishing how
much did you talk yeah
PSB without fire paper is really tough
don't run out of them actually I'm going
to add some pungent boys yeah putting
blood definitely makes you know what's
funny I've never used pungent blood
against him but that is a PSP yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah I never really used it
though that's actually good strap I
forgot about that I think the only thing
I ever used really was against Amelia I
used those the like anti heel bottles
that was kind of about it though but
Amelia yeah I think fire also yeah fire
hurts are really bad I think it stops
feeling I don't know if it stops her
healing but I know that she's like weak
to it yeah might be she's a week two in
the of the the other one stops her
healing
all right let's see if we can do it I
believe
so chilled ones favorite weapon mood
lights art it's a good shout I like it
that it I don't know could technically
by Gasca wins are worth you know not
that you need it
I bid just beats Ludwig on old hundreds
of say congrats excise a pain in the
butt
there's multiple ways to get the badge
from him if you didn't know they ever
gene star win well that's a throwback
love that anime where's Jess McDonald
she's in Australia she's an Oscar I
don't know even what time it is for them
right now to be honest it's a good
question what time is it
pretty sure it's uh I think it's earlier
right like Japan time no 6 a.m. damn
fish depending on what region but
never liked using items during boss
fights yeah they're in the game it's up
to you if you want to use them or not
self-imposed challenge keep close to BSB
if just circle the pillars yeah yeah I
mean for me BSP was always about
managing the GD poison will they ever
make a second blood-borne one can only
hope
one can only hope but you hunt we're
ready to face the HUD except not really
because we're not gonna deal with you
just good here just drop down to the
right okay I'm taking a quick stroll
getting some stuff
hello there how can you call a game
overrated before you even play the big
boss that is crazy
I mean I mean there's definitely a lot
of hype around it sure yeah I think you
can call it over eighty yeah guy wait
till the games out for you Ming that
there's been a lot of games this year as
well for the person that said there's
not a game well there's tons yeah I feel
like games haven't stopped this year
slowed down video games
you know there's actually a way not to
kill the guy the minigun and actually
can be friends with them yeah if you
don't fight you need them beat if I
think if you go kill the boss start
beast without attacking him at all and
then I think you might have to avoid
fighting a bunch of these guys I don't
remember that part so there is there is
a way to do it yes I've never done it
but I've never done either I always made
his ass roll off the building oh it's so
blown out yeah I mean the only way we
can really do that adjusting the audio
watch out some guys are coming out of
the wall man video games are the best
yeah we do with that you go to the
gunner now I think
yeah you wanna take this back
and the roof for the
where this from being pretty tough my
first time through
there's not too much stuff up here
though if I recall correctly it's more
about doing a balancing act what's it
like to work for GameSpot that's what
interests me it's a lot of fun I mean
clearly we have the absolute pleasure of
being able to play games and hang out
with you guys and no it's it's a fun
thing to know that you're going to work
- you know they talk about video games
play video games make videos about video
games
it's definitely a dream come true a lot
of work but days like this where it's
like I get to go play blood-borne this
morning it's pretty awesome
okay so you guys didn't know thank you
guys for tuning in and we're playing
blood-borne sponsored by PlayStation now
you can learn more about that at PS now
calm currently this is the downloaded
version from PS now replace aging now
then you can also stream it if you want
it to be technically it's about to get
spicy I'm surprised you even ever gonna
deal with them
because these are some angry boys
got funneling
you got that slow poisoning I hear they
were just gonna be guys behind me - yeah
they should
talk about spicy that was too spicy -
spicy wrong place Rendon Oh Lane or Lana
Lana Knorr mine does working for viewing
this ain't make you play video games
less for fun I don't think so not for me
but there are definitely times really
because you need to take a break see
some nature you know occasionally it's
good for you cuz can't you go up down
over there you can but you gotta unlock
that first really yeah that's that's the
short that's the shortcut to get to the
Beast there first
oh that must have totally spaced they
forgot about that cuz would you get
technically get stuck then if you know
there's a lot of you can get back up oh
you drop down and you can go know as
much as you want to fire back today oh
boy
spicy my heart is like now like this
young Luke
oh that was very scary for a second
spicy indeed okay guys slowly walk it up
taking this time I will get to you wait
for me
good hunter I'm here maybe he just
wasn't trained to climb ladders you know
at a young age call obsidian says I love
this game so much I wish I could erase
it from my mind and play it again you
could technically do pure self into
thinking that it doesn't exist that gasp
haze rip County's a wood yeah I guess I
died once
that's a pretty good fun fact okay I
just want to get my souls back and then
run past those boys then we're gonna
fight mr. backstreet's back oh how did
that not hit you or did it hit you
push it I am now in some kind of force
what do I do next
you got to find the three three wise men
and defeat them to get past the forest
which forest and uh yeah he's in the
hematite which forces you talking about
uh I guess that's true
talking about the snake forest yeah
thanks City I think snake City aw thanks
I don't know those that's why city's
actually my least favorite part of this
game makes it makes it ISA that's when
they're actually like hey there's a coin
system you can use it never he states so
big and it's so easy to get lost like
ice never used didn't even though that
mechanic was in the game I still get
lost in snake city told me it's totally
doable and we can always go a little
longer and I might have mold to for
blood-borne my god that's a boss hashtag
blood-borne bias alright so here is it
like some I think since got my stuff you
think it's up here or you do down there
kind of died around here so it could be
one of these boys to be this guy maybe
see you have to look at the eyes nope
did he call his friends though
yep
all right time well that guy doesn't
have neither so okay things are about to
get spicy again yeah it's fine
fighting on your terms they're slowly
making their way I see I see them all
they're like gonna getcha
can i play blood-borne if I have a
severe phobia of blood ah
he turned the blood effect off no okay
there's a lot of blood in this game so
probably the blood makes you
uncomfortable then just say that's a jam
or a ketchup or something say alien
blood that's why it's pg-13 it's not
exactly hello there sir
Oh see in physical wall for him that's
too big it's not that's why it's not
packing works out for me though hey guys
what's up oh I see him the guy with your
souls yeah
he's behind this dude
who resembles a nice raspberry marmalade
sense the wishes my gosh it's red paint
you gray says I honestly can't get any
of souls games I really don't get why
they were so popular oh it definitely
takes a certain person or player to
enjoy these games blood-borne
specifically I adore the aesthetic and
then I found the combat very satisfying
all right
we did it we did it all sort of look
it's kind of like a blood star beast yes
I get one I think they like bags blame
that in the law or something this is
something for the child engines right or
maybe now maybe it's the other after you
beat him no you have to beat the witch
in him with Charlaine to get the child's
dungeon stuff well for some reason I
thought you got one of those things off
like one of these I think I think you
maybe get one of the chalices for being
him but then to get the Carroll ruins
you have to that's a shortcut but that's
a different shortcut act you know what
you're here just for safety we'll do
this one as well but I end up never
using this one because I just unlock the
better one
for safety purposes just in case dude I
remember how long I played this game
without knowing there's a run in
climbing faster
God what a time-saver alright so BSB is
down there yep
a row Stinson
yeah I got some pebbles that's kind of a
bridge that I crossed earlier I swear I
fought the clerk the clerk bees
this games really cool like that
like Dark Souls one where you doing this
is dumb I just totally got lost here for
a longest time and didn't realize I had
to walk through there to your left right
yeah yeah yeah I I didn't even see this
pathway the first time I played I was
like where am I going
alright there's definitely boys here
yeah in the smoke they're like hiding in
them Rosi crows
all right chat forget new you're over
under that we're gonna kill BSB I know
you're there
the wolf yeah whoopie pie multi times
there's a couple wolfy times right here
there's a bunch actually yeah but
specifically right here this - oh he's
showing you his but he was presenting
this is why that shortcut was a good
idea
don't get got yeah you're like I enough
climbing around ooh it's pretty good to
get a shard off that guy yeah I should
upgrade before I fight the Beast let's
go over to John Luke gets them first try
wow that's of confidence Bob Jones got
him here we go and they're just dropping
the shards
I call this way is just the door that's
plural yeah it's pearl you can't open it
from the side you have to open it from
the other side to do that's why it's
like you unlike a shortcut to here yeah
it's like it's real dumb I guess it's
like if you never did the blood to beast
you that would be yeah but but it's like
parles way harder than the beasts so
chilled one says three deaths was that
under I'll take the under two and a half
I'll take I don't be what I'm telling
you once that was like my I think didn't
feel like early in my name and that was
I didn't I was I didn't beat him over
the weekend I was struggling I didn't
all right so this is to get the shortcut
right yeah are you sure you couldn't
have gone through this way there's a
door you gotta unlock okay you're
probably right yeah you literally played
this this weekend so you know
it's a dude here right yep
well at least we're getting big upgrades
here yeah we're able to upgrade yep then
you can make your way back up is this
where you got the mists or is this
forget there's too many climbing ladders
shirt cards are useless I definitely
wouldn't agree with that I mean the
shortcuts are very useful for for boss
stuff yeah is mainly what it is just
means an extra a couple seconds into
climbing a ladder climb a ladder back up
hate that ladder though and there we go
I think you've got this John Luke says
philanthropy thank you it's been
positive energy channel it three tries
are bust as the heal I'll give him three
tries and I want to try once if it comes
yeah if it comes to it absolutely but I
don't know I had the blender bust
let's don't be shocked and easy to get
used to the game I don't disagree that I
know it's easy to pair your game stuff
I'm just everyone just has their deal
whatever reason it's the one that always
makes me panic the most I think it's
something out the poisoner he's a gross
boy gross
so whether I see into the matrix today
or not but I feel good I feel good about
John Luke's attempt here so I don't even
think it's gonna come to that
first before I spend do some upgrade
possibly probably level two right hole
level three wow we are falling as well
some visit a cup all right technically a
fire paper - right
I do fire paper doesn't really hurt them
okay it's not as effective well I sing a
Backstreet song for ultimate fire up
backstreet's back old yarny all right
crying things first try all right
I mean first try would be two minutes
when we normally end the stream we're
gonna go a little longer because I want
to give John leave this time to kill him
ooh hardest boss of this decade orphan
of cost in this game our Valkyrie queen
and got a war Oh about your coin was
pretty tough she was pretty tough
actually never got to her because I just
wasn't interested in doing on the
Valkyries but I'm sure she would've been
pretty tough she was pretty tough for me
at least took me a little bit I
eventually got her it's pretty tough I
don't know those are those are two good
shouts Ludwig was harder than cost for
me though I don't know why he was like
the gatekeeper he like literally kept me
from doing the rest of like old hunters
time now he's like you shall not pass
young hunter he was a gross boy to just
walk past that guy are you gonna run by
these guys maybe sb+ our pcs as many of
this air weapon there's so much damage
now you compare the earlier are those
antidotes right on what oh there's a
dead body to the right but don't worry
about it
I can check his antidotes looks like
right around the corner here right
behind ya sorry that way sorry
take to the right oh oh sorry there it
is there it is
wasn't worth it well it might be worth
it depending depends how you look at it
I definitely use a lot of bullets
against a BSB alright alright do I dare
turn this up too much I'm fine as it is
okay wish send us all the energy Oh God
again I don't want this one's always my
mic here we go no you can't think that
way
[Music]
Rippy gross boy great start
yep oh that's unfortunate I know that
feelings okay the light bulbs
that's fine no poison Oh
one thing you can do it okay
[Music]
oh nice nice yeah reading the book
that's that away really tough to do
nice
oh that's so unfortunate the little
backswing
it's okay
reset just just have a little casual
reset here yeah I appreciate that
nice
that fine don't go hit
he's in realizing he's being generous
home run oh dang he sensed it
yeah like when he got his butt attack
[Music]
come on yeah we'll slap to the face
loving the poison get ready to bathe in
it big poison boy Oh
it's fine that's right there's good
[Music]
so angry you guys notice how when from
three swings to five yes I remember the
first time that was layup so bad killing
think you know your poison boy okay I
was not paying attention okay
I was like I don't want to say anything
but ah you're poison that was uh it was
good it was good well I quit cuz I was
actually a really good run all right you
got it
I was just so focused on him at the
moment I didn't realize I was poison
that's like dang I was like man Jenna
looks be a real bold he's poisoning he
still going back anymore no I was not
paying attention okay I should buy some
antidotes so give me a sec to sing
bye-bye but that's not a Backstreet Boys
song though by my vibes insane are you
trying to test me you bulls that was a
rough day boy it's you see that's I
think that's the kind of like the trick
in blood start is having to manage
poison but then also manage the boss is
I kind of one of those things you don't
deal with too much you kind of get it a
little bit here well you definitely
don't get it to the degree of what
happens during blood start beast copilot
fail hey I was trying not to get in his
head and by the time I asked it was too
late
it was definitely too late so yeah it
was my fault I guess I should have said
something sooner but sometimes you know
you copilot and then you're like oh and
then you know he was gonna use antidote
and if he died that way wouldn't be my
fault too so there was no winning there
just an blame yeah I was like he's in
the zone I'm just gonna not say anything
that was a failure on my own I stopped
paying attention okay hopefully I should
be able to buy some some people are
saying to use fire paper but I didn't
know that it actually did that once you
got those stars fire paper to be that
useful with them personally but I didn't
really ever use it though I definitely
used it against
alright let's let's get her salsa to do
anyway more than two uh you had six so
you only used for really if you think
about section so if you have about five
you're probably okay just get what I can
yeah
they go to all right you got four
they're more expensive than I
anticipated all right that's before I
think is roughly where you would have
been so you just gotta play a little bit
tighter I suppose also there's another
item that if you play through it a
little bit more makes it a little bit
easier the cleric robes have like
big-time anti poison I think so if you
technically pick that up too it would
actually it actually helps as well
Jonathan says fire paper and blood
cocktail I'm thinking the pungent come
to my gas going stuff okay it's coins
cap
never get now I have good old blood
blood fashion fashion is born all right
here we go
fireworks work on all big beasts I guess
that's true I guess you could take that
blood cocktail into the wall and use
fire paper fire paper might not be bad
actually I think he had it in all
honesty like there's a couple there's a
couple are two whiffs maybe but I mean
other than that and not seeing the
poison the very end I think to stuff
stuff about everything else was fine to
be honest they say fire paper that like
why not we're gonna end the stream with
his boss anyways so why not give it use
it for that extra damage and then we
could thank chat later if it works out
who you're also fighting at a
disadvantage in terms of miles but I
mean 17 should be plenty I should be
able to get a couple shoot chose the
threaded kit yeah right get out of here
with your threaded cane I refuse I know
it works at the bite at this point I
think I missed the huge 30k in the fan
man goop says you get one more death to
cover the bet yeah two and a half are
you just okay Wow people like the xxx
candle on it saying it's Opie I don't
buy it there's so many other weapons I'd
rather use in this game than the 30 came
but our game is at the absolute bottom
for me Finnish champs I can go to sleep
we're trying we're definitely
giving it all john least giving him is
his all I'm kind of just here is
motivational support and this time I'll
try to tell you if there's a poison do
you not get fall damage you do it just
depends on how high you are what more
blood shards by the way yep I'm pretty
sure this point it switches to our twin
shards so I can't upgrade anymore yeah
cuz you're at three oh there's your
souls or something
no that's if I want to call Alfred oh
right yeah sorry cuz I've seen him walk
fast we're just kind of doing whatever
happens it on we're trying to get
through three boss oh yeah yeah I don't
use the goal here
all right round two y'all very good
with a fire paper that bit more yes
staggered for a face too
close oh that's the battle one that's
the one that'll one-shot me yeah that's
the worst one that's the worst one at
least you didn't use an antidote yeah
vicar VA already dead no dang we just
happened to go to VSP first oh that
sucks
all right and then we'll see a BSB is
the one that conquers us on this dream
although I still I still hold out hope
here third time's the charm gentlemen
their time hopefully what do you guys do
if you're streaming you need a P very
badly you hold it or you just say I
gotta go and I'll mute my mic and think
there is the time right it was just like
I gotta go I'll be right back I'll be
back I will actually be right back l won
to open with more damage Oh still good
nailed it
you're saving time you don't need these
antidote or vials nor do I remember nor
do i is i this one I struggled with a
lot my first time playing through doing
this multiple times sometimes getting
too cocky and accidentally being like I
should just stop sometimes you gotta
take a break actually sometimes you find
out that like you take a half an hour
hour break and come back and you
one-shot it's just because you're just
banging your head on the table like a
walk yeah you just needed a refresh you
know yeah I've done that many times
alright well oh hello as I choke round
three
super unfortunate John Luke's not
leaving me any wiggle room so he's
definitely got a killer because at this
rate I'm gonna have like five maybe a
little time to farm because then I might
have to farm antidote to depending on
how well you do open cleaver don't
charge shot fire paper dodging that yeah
I mean that works for you everyone plays
this game different let him play
the way John Luke wants to play but
thank you for the tips we do appreciate
what we're just saying that you know
everyone got their own style you know
like the stagger worked earlier and if
gonna continue to work nobody here would
be saying anything great that's fine
shake it off it's early who we got
autumn that goes back okay
she's some tree like that you're like
that bothering me yeah
that one's a hard one the time I feel
like I usually dodge that one I think
yeah get lit up oh wow that did a lot of
damage actually holy smokes 634 on that
combo four-hitter yeah okay you try the
open didn't work it's okay
on to p2
okay nice nice tender there Oh through
the wall and poison I'm good
yep yep yep don't forget later that you
don't have antidote equipped but it's
fine no big deal hey Dudley gets all in
I like it that's such a wide swing
okay
oh this is great shout out to chat for
the fire paper the fire paper is doing
work okay you don't need that antidote
that's sometimes you don't need it slow
poison
five hitter
nice all right back in business
okay good you're good I'm poison so
that's good mmm having a break here
while he poisons up again
[Applause]
okay
there it is hey hey didn't need me I
told you I had so much faith I was like
uh he feels so good he's burning through
all the paper it doesn't matter cuz he's
gonna kill him and what happened third
time's a charm again we nailed it did it
nailed it hundred percent Oh as I got
Herrick don't say anything let me tell
him the important things I was like I
was gonna tell you like you're at half
health
you should really heal but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna say that
all right great work John Luke thank you
so much that was blood-borne we were
playing web born sponsored to you buy a
Playstation now if you want to know more
about that you should check out PS now
calm that wraps up today's stream though
again sponsored by PlayStation now thank
you guys all for tuning in you can
stream hundreds of ps4 ps3 and PS to
games directly to your console or PC
game or PC sorry with new games being
added every month in addition you can
download any ps4 game in the service on
to your console to play at any time
which supports titles such as Mortal
Kombat 10 until dawn for honor and pray
and again to learn more PS I'll calm
thank you so much John Luke for getting
through that absolutely we did mostly
what we said we were we we only went
over by like 15 ish minutes about we
thank the chat for their continued
support for sending us all the energy I
appreciate it you guys yeah gave me life
there you go
see told you told you he was gonna do it
for those that few that didn't believe
there is a few but we got there anyways
what wars a great game you should play
it play it before
Seki ro comes out which is in about 11
days looking forward to that any final
thoughts charlie
nah man that was fun a lot of fun I'm
looking forward to second row yeah can't
wait alright thanks so much peace
[Music]